breaking news showing breaking news as
the helicopters are overhead the Austin
Police Department have just tweeted out
quote there was no package explosion in
the 900 block of the 9800 block of Brody
Lane items inside the package were not a
bomb rather an incendiary device I
repeat an incendiary device at this time
they have no reason to believe that this
incident the incendiary device is
related to the previous package bombs so
I am very you know I don't understand it
in it could this be a second a second
attacker although how to want to intern
with it and iary device how do we
interpret what an incendiary device is
what does that mean well I would imagine
like a flare or you know something like
a firework some kind of you know more
flame than bang an explosion is an
incendiary device in a closed container
that explodes because there's no place
for the energy to go and incendiary
device is more we're efforting more
specifics on exactly what the incendiary
device consisted of hopefully the Austin
Police Department will give us some
guidance but clearly there was some kind
of you know maybe the person was burned
rather than blown you know injured in
terms of the explosion well without this
quoting from the from the police it's an
incendiary device not a package
explosion Sean okay the whole Aldo stay
right there we'll get back to you